hello everyone and welcome back to the
second half of our tardigrade
reproduction spectacular in our last
episode we got a very close look though
I suppose all of our looks are pretty
close at the various biological
intimacy's exchanged by tardigrades as
they mate multiple males contended for
the heart or at least the unfertilized
eggs of a female tardigrade by poking
endlessly at her Exodia it was really
quite dramatic and if you haven't
watched it yet you should it's great
there's poop but now it is time for the
thrilling conclusion to all of that
mating the babies this tardigrade has
been lugging her future offspring in a
sack made up of her EXO via which is her
shedded exoskeleton like a spare room
that's been converted into a baby
nursery the same exodia that started as
the mother's own cuticle before it
became the site of courtship has now
undergone another renovation to become a
handy portable egg nursery the ways the
tardigrades deal with their eggs may
look different for different species
while this water bear carries her EXO
via at the end of her body
some species carry it more towards the
front some don't lay eggs in exuviae at
all while another species has been seen
depositing their eggs in the exodia of
water fleas why our species has evolved
or chosen this method is unknown to us
maybe it allows her to provide them
protection or perhaps she could ensure
they hatch in the best possible location
this way we just don't know
we did very much want to observe this
mother-to-be and so for three days we
followed her doing our best to also take
good care of her and the biggest concern
was making sure she wouldn't get too dry
so he had to keep her away from the
edges of the slide to do this we used
only the most advanced techniques we
poked her with the fine hair from a
brush to push her towards the more
watery regions of the slide we even set
an alarm to remind us to add a drop of
water to the slide every four hours yes
even at night it's a lot of alarms now
you might be thinking aren't tardigrades
supposed to be the hardiest creatures on
earth able to withstand extreme
conditions hypothetical apocalypses and
maybe even crash landings on the moon
surely they do not require this level of
helicopter parenting or I guess it's
grand parenting
well we do care a lot for all of our
microscopic organisms and so it could be
that this watery vigil is just an
abundance of caution on our part but
we've seen with our own eyes that no
matter how tough tardigrades may be the
micro cosmos is tougher sometimes things
just happen and not in the way you might
hope
you might remember this tardigrade from
a previous episode we were pretty
excited about her because we could see
all of those eggs just ready to be
hatched but the mother was completely
still she hadn't moved at all which
would usually be worrisome but she
wasn't decomposing so we thought maybe
she was still alive just biting the time
until her eggs hatched and so while she
waited so did we gestation and
tardigrades can vary quite a bit not
just by species but with temperature and
just plain old chance it generally takes
a few days but it can take months we
kept her in a humidity chamber and
checked in to make sure the coverslip
wasn't crushing her but the inactive
tardigrade never became active again
eventually her body did begin to
decompose as did the eggs inside her and
so this tardigrade family was not meant
to be we don't know what killed this
tardigrade but it's hard not to feel
responsible for the organisms we film
sure they're unaware of our existence
but they are in our care and like the
animals and humans we come to feel
connected to it's sad to be reminded
that endings can come for even the
mightiest creatures among us even if
they are also among the smallest that's
why when we later found the impending
tardigrade mother that started this
episode we took so much care to keep her
alive it was nerve-racking because we
didn't want to lose another brood
hence the 4-hour alarms and the brush
hair so you might be able to imagine our
combined excitement and relief when
after four days of this intensive care
we saw a tardigrade cuticle that was no
longer full of eggs
it was full of eggshells and baby
tardigrades unfortunately it turned out
that getting footage of the actual
hatching during this moment was
challenging the eggs would roll around
in the cuticle while also being dragged
by the mother but you can see the baby
tardigrades clawing their way through
the mass of eggs eventually though the
mother finally completely shed her
cuticle you can see it here it almost
looks like a tardigrade ghost chasing
behind her this moment was particularly
fortuitous for us because as the
tardigrade rid herself of the exodia
that had housed her future children one
unhatched egg came out as well it's
weird to look at this and realize that
in a few moments out will come a
tardigrade just an oval with some lines
in it a formed thing packed away that
arrow shaped thing that's pumping away
is the tardigrades style' it's a part of
their mouth that pokes out when it comes
time to eat and it helps the tardigrade
suction out the meatiness of the
microbes that it feeds on but before
they can get to eating the stylet s--
have an important task helping the baby
tardigrade get out of their shell after
2 hours of struggling the stylus of the
tardigrade begin to move more
repetitively until finally it's able to
poke holes in the egg those holes allow
water into the egg increasing the
pressure inside until the egg just pops
and out comes
a little moss piglet and with it a new
generation is born adding to a lineage
of mighty microscopic animals stretching
back hundreds of millions of years
[Music]
if you heard a sigh just then it's a
sigh of relief and joy from all of us at
the micro cosmos team when we set out to
track and record a tardigrade birth we
didn't know that it would lead to both
heartbreak and excitement but it's all
worth it for this little buddy
among many we hope to see them all again
perhaps creating their own brood but for
now paddle away our little friend the
whole micro cosmos awaits
[Music]
thank you for coming on this journey
with us as we explore the unseen world
that surrounds us journey to the micro
cosmos is produced by complexly if you
want to keep imagining the world
complexly with us you can check out
animal wonders a youtube channel hosted
by Jesse Knudsen Castaneda animal
wonders is an animal rescue and
education facility that cares for close
to a hundred exotic animals and
non-releasable wildlife every week on
the animal wonders YouTube channel jesse
features a different animal and shares
what it's like to keep them happy and
healthy
recently Jesse and the animal wonders
team took in piggley the arctic fox if
you'd like to learn all about piggley's
story and find out how he's getting
along with the other foxes at animal
wonders there's a link in the
description to a video all about that
and here is a list of all of the people
who support us on patreon thank you so
much to all of them for allowing us to
go on this journey and allowing us to
take so many other people along with us
you can be one of those people and get
some really cool perks just go ahead and
check out patreon.com/crashcourse
all of his amazing work and skill if
you'd like to see more of what he does
you can check out Jam and germs on
Instagram and if you'd like to see more
of what we do just go to youtube.com
slash micro cosmos where you can find
our entire first season of videos and
also click on that subscribe button so
you can find a new video every single
week okay bye
you